whole water park just like
the rock n roll take over
nick cannon knows how to make a splash
literally
renting out an entire water park for his
twins moroccan and monroe
[Music]
[Applause]
the cannons get wet and wild riding down
a water slide and enjoys some summertime
fun i love children i want to i try to
document everything like that nick
documented the day on instagram and
eleven-year-old rock and roll whom he
shares with ex mariah carey clearly
having a blast
of course the proud dad is no stranger
to going all out for his mini-mes i go
all the way last month nick opened up to
e.t about one of his most cherished
memories
when daddy went big i mean really big
when they turned two we shut down
disneyland and like it was the kids uh
second birthday yep it was the same day
he renewed his vows with mimi we're in
the castle it was a mate like i said
fairy tale memories there's no way that
i could ever have an experience like
that again and we're still so like close
friends the best of friends great
parents together so i appreciate you
know that time in my life since that
ball renewal in 2013 nick and mariah
have called it quits but continue to be
great co-parents
the twin thing is
it's difficult it's a huge blessing it
really is the greatest thing that ever
happened to me and with super talent
from both mom and dad the star power is
in the twin's blood
[Music]
we've seen glimpses of rock and rose
shining with their mom on tick tock like
when they sang mariah's hit with bust of
rhymes i know what you want
and maybe one day we could see rock and
roll join their dad's hit show wildin
out at least that's what he teased to us
i'm gonna be honest that's like that my
kid's probably gonna be starting on
wildin out uh 32. and these days nick's
definitely got a full crew you just show
up with all my thousand kids last month
the 41 year old welcomed his eighth
child a baby boy named legendary love
with model bree tac being a father is my
first priority in life and re-reiterated
nick's doing a great job juggling his
daddy duties everyone is loved and taken
care of and accepted and welcomed
everywhere
[Music]
you